president Trump is interviewing federal
judges to see which one may be promoted
to the Supreme Court
the president has narrowed his list of
potential replacements for Justice
Anthony Kennedy from twenty five to
seven and there are two women on that
short list and one person of color chip
Reid is at the White House chip good
morning
well good morning the White House is
putting together a team some call it a
war room to help the president pick his
nominee by his deadline of this coming
Monday and then get that nominee
confirmed by October they are really
incredible people in so many different
ways speaking to reporters in the Oval
Office President Trump called his
interviews with four potential Supreme
Court nominees quote very interesting
and said he would be meeting with two or
three more candidates I think the person
that is chosen will be outstanding
according to the Washington Post
president Trump interviewed four federal
appeals court judges Brett Kavanaugh Amy
Cooney Barrett Amitha par and Raymond
Catholic Cavanaugh clerked for Justice
Kennedy and worked in the George W Bush
White House at his confirmation hearing
in 2006 he said he considered roe v wade
to be settled law if confirmed to the DC
Circuit I would follow roe v wade
faithfully and fully Barrett a former
Notre Dame law professor grabbed the
attention of conservatives last year
when she defended her Catholic faith in
her confirmation hearing my religious
belief would not bear in the discharge
of my duties as a judge sipar would be
the first Indian American judge on the
Supreme Court from Kentucky he is a
favorite of Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Catholic who's been on the
Sixth Circuit Court of Appeals for a
decade told senators at his confirmation
hearing the best judges are ones who
seek to apply precedent in good faith
press secretary Sarah Sanders said the
president is not asking candidates about
their views on roe v wade as the
president said last week he's not going
to discuss specific cases with those
nominees Republican senator Lisa
Murkowski of Alaska who supports
abortion rights says she would like the
nominee to be in the mold of Anthony
Kennedy the retiring Supreme Court
justice who was often a swing vote and
by the way later today the president
will be
with another female candidate that is
judge Joan Larson of the Sixth Circuit
Court of Appeals
Anthony chip Reed thank you chip